if you get the financing to make
anything you want what would you make
and why
whoa
that is such a good question uh
better nathan ever too because i think
nate has more adventures in him steve
i well you wrote you've already written
two sequels it's true i somehow against
all odds have a trilogy of books i think
the answer and this is true is that like
disney has such a trove of ip
that that i'm just starting to sort of
imagine you know what what's the back
story and what's the
you know what's the next big thing that
could just be an absolute blast to dive
into
and uh and i love musicals and i love
sort of like big magical worlds and so
i'm i'm i'm going through long lists
right now trying to find that next big
thing um if you could go back in time
and i know you're a broadway fan you can
go back in time
to any previous broadway production and
watch it what would you watch and why i
mean incredible question
i think i would go to the opening night
of cats on broadway
because i'd want to know if people in
the audience thought it was insane
that people were like crawling around in
unitards howling and singing
or if it really was the sort of
instantly iconic broadway smash that
history tells us it was it's so campy
and bizarre and cats to me is sort of
the uh
example of the sort of highs and lows of
theater you've got like the
the incredible music and also the
incredible absurdity of adults with
whiskers
and and i wanted to bring some of that
high and low to this movie as well
it is very great it is
it is so weird that that is the
production that lasted for so long
different yeah i was like but i do
remember when i first moved to new york
city
there were ads and the tagline for cats
was now and forever and when i first
moved there it was like now and forever
closing this january
they're like even cats nine lives but
eventually everyone hits their tenth
life
how talk a little bit about the journey
of making this film uh you obviously
wrote the book was this something that
almost was directed by somebody else
were you holding this back to be like
i'm i'm making this movie
i've been wanting to make a better
nathan ever filmed for a while but um i
think a lot of things had to happen i
had to have like the perfect cast and i
think you know ruby wood and aria
co-star in the film
that they they were the perfect age they
were both 14 when we shot it any other
time in the history of the world they
would have been too young or or they
would have outgrown it and then in my
experience show running high school
musical for the last three years you get
such a crash course in all things stress
and script writing and
time management and so it all sort of
converged at the same time to be uh i
think perfect timing
well listen this movie doesn't work
without uh ruby and i'm just what was it
like casting
and getting ruby because
were you nervous after casting him that
you're like we gotta start filming i
don't want him to grow six inches i
don't want his voice to change do you
know what i mean yeah i worked on the
show billy elliot on broadway and just
when the guys would go into the show and
and learn every dance and learn every
song almost a week later their voice
would change and so for a role like nate
who is right at the center of a
coming-of-age story about identity and
finding his people
you know i had to find a kid who really
represented that authentically the
biggest risk with ruby wood was that he
had never appeared on camera he's like a
real deal theater kid and i had a lot of
spirited conversations with disney uh he
had seven callbacks because i saw
something in him that was um
like a
diamond in the rough in in in every in
in every sense of that phrase he was not
yet shining perfectly but i knew he
would get there and and he was i thought
astonishing in the role oh ruby is very
good in the role uh there you you cast
uh uh you know you nailed it on that one
thank you um
so listen i love talking to directors
about the editing room uh just because
that's where it all comes together so
how did this film possibly change in the
editing room versus what you expected i
have this incredible editor named katie
macquarie who uh cut a bunch of the coen
brothers films and she and i were in
collaboration even during production
because i went in with a really really
tight shot list
um that was very much inspired by edgar
wright the transitions edgar does so
famously that are so rude and fast and
funny um but i also wanted to evoke the
sort of coming-of-age adventures films
of the 80s and so how it changed in
editing is that i like music to really
drive a lot of emotion
and so when you have a composer like
gabriel mann who's best known for modern
family and he's making his big feature
debut with this film we worked
hand-in-hand where i would send him a
clip and say i think this can be funnier
i think i've done everything i can do
with picture what do you got and two
hours later gabe would be like try this
and he'd send something back with a
xylophone and i'd be like we did it
so a lot of the editing room is like you
get to write the final draft of the
movie
oh a hundred percent did you end up with
a lot of deleted scenes or no
we have a handful of deleted scenes and
and they were only deleted because they
either took away from pacing
or they took off took us off nate's
journey i sort of think of better nate
than ever as ferris bueller for theater
kids
and so nate is very much the matthew
broderick ferris bueller of the film and
i think the through line of the film is
a kid who's a big dork in his hometown
who wants to get out and make something
of himself and anything deleted was
anything extraneous that didn't sort of
support that adventure
i definitely have to ask you before i
run out of time what is it like getting
the keys to sister act i mean i grew up
as a sister act superfan i could still
sing joyful joyful lauren hill the
second movie
and so
the opportunity to sort of take a
franchise uh like sister act the same
way i was sort of handed high school
musical it's a complete honor and my
dream is to get nuns singing you know
all across the world do you is it how is
the script progressing on that are you
actually going to be filming this year
i i hope we are you know i think the
sister act franchise is a big priority
to the studio script's coming along and
i think whoopi's really excited and and
now it's just about schedules and chips
falling where they may i've heard the
word scheduling from so many directors
that it is i don't think people realize
outside of town what that word really
it's everything it's it's literally like
the availability of a convent and the
availability of a
of an egot
um what are you thinking about for
directing in the future are you hoping
to possibly make besides sister act are
you hoping to possibly make a sequel to
this are you looking towards other
another musical
i would love to expand the nate
cinematic universe um i will say you
know rob marshall's kind of my hero when
i was 12 years old rob marshall directed
me in a production of oliver in my
hometown of pittsburgh and i have been
quietly following in his footsteps and
in his shadow for almost 30 years and so
what he's been able to do creating these
beautiful visual musical event films um
is kind of my dream too on that note i
got to stop i'm just going to say again
uh really congrats on this and i really
i really sincerely hope it's a big hit
for you guys
it means a lot to me stephen thank you
i'm a huge collider fan it means a lot
thank you
you